[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on instrument
qualification for a quality management
system by justin haugen
i am bill and liker from thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be moderating
today's event
before we begin i want to encourage you
to engage with us you can submit as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
simply type them into the ask the
question box on the left and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
please welcome justin
hey thanks bill my name is justin haugen
and i'm representing the thermo fisher
scientific life sciences division uh i'm
a
field service engineer three at thermo
fisher scientific
in the u.s west district i'm responsible
for the installation and validation of
next-gen sequencing as well as qpcr
instrumentation
my career started at novartis where i
was responsible for protein purification
in a protein crystallography lab then i
joined ge healthcare as a field service
engineer serving servicing the
purification systems
in 2011 i joined thermo fisher
scientific where i become a senior level
service engineer managing customer
accounts in san diego county
i was asked to be a part of this webinar
because a lot of my work involves
performing qualifications on a variety
of thermo-fisher platforms
let's quickly review the learning
objectives of this webinar
we will learn where a qualification
comes from
what process validation is and how
qualifications fit
what a thermofisher scientific
qualification provides
how they are organized iq oq and pq
and when
qualifications are performed
finally why qualifications are important
qualifications are an industry standard
what does that mean it means that
leaders of industry in our case this
would be biotechnology instrumentation
have come together and agreed to use
this mechanism as a response to
regulations and standards to document
performance
now quality cases are not
just the domain of biotechnology
instrumentation it has been accepted in
a multitude of business segments ranging
from aerospace
food processing and silicone chip
manufacturing
even package shipping adopted
qualification
an example is amazon
when they build out a local warehouse
they install what is called a conveyance
system to move more move orders from
fulfillment to logistics for delivery
they perform a qualification of the
conveyance system and computer system
validation of the software and computers
that employees use to process your
orders
our thermo fisher scientific
qualification
documents that the instrument is
installed
operating and performing to the
manufacturer's design specifications it
is performed by a trained and certified
service engineer such as myself and you
will receive a document as well as
supporting attachments
as we have mentioned qualifications are
an industry standard accepted in
response to regulations
what would be an example of such
regulations directly applicable to
thermo fisher scientific customer
and our instrumentation is quality
system requirements of productions and
process controls and process validation
if we dig deep into
820.70g it defines the essentials of
what equipment performance needs to be
documented
we have highlighted the pertinent
language
that guy that guidance interprets for
the industry
again it's not calling out the iqopq
mechanism but rather what needs to be
documented
subsections for maintenance inspection
adjustment of equipment are specific to
each manufacturer's recommendation and
design
for one the maintenance schedule each
manufacturer shall establish and
maintain schedules and records for the
adjustment cleaning and other
maintenance of the equipment to ensure
that manufacturing specifications are
met
maintenance activities include the date
and individuals performing the
maintenance activities shall be
documented for two inspection
each manufacturer shall conduct periodic
inspections and records in accordance
with established procedures to ensure
adherence to applicable equipment
maintenance and schedules
the inspections include the date and
individuals conducting the inspections
should be documented
number three
adjustment each manufacturer shall
ensure an inherent limitations or
allowable tolerances and records are
visibly posted on or near the equipment
when a new laboratory equipment or
instrumentation is installed into a
workflow an iq oqpq should be
the
performed
of equipment instrumentation and
associated software is an integral part
of the process validation here is a
specific code of federal regulation
sections of prop for process validation
this code of federal regulation and the
complementary iso standards applicable
for medical devices
13485 require that validation of a
process particularly manufacturing shall
be performed
we have highlighted some of the
important
language that
guidance documents help interpret
subsection a calls out the process
validation need to be done that needs to
be done for example where results cannot
be fully verified subsection b calls out
details of who what how and when of a
process foundation
qualified individuals shall be
documented
in stated requirements with a process to
review and evaluate reinvalid
where appropriate
for perspective to better understand
subsection b we have provided provided
the fda quality systems definition of
establish
establish means define document and
implement
the objective of
validation is to produce that documented
evidence provide a high degree of
confidence to or assurance that all
parts in scope will consistently
function according to specification when
called into use
so what does process validation look
like here is a high level overview
there could be a lot of steps detailed
but here are have here we have a few
broken out into major milestones
any validation starts with the
development of a plan
for
for our purposes this would move into
the qualification of hardware and
instrumentation data is collected and
organized into validation report
and if
the plan inputs are met the workflow is
it is in specification and can be
released
the objective of qualification is to
produce documented evidence
that an instrument is in a workflow is
performing within the manufacturer's
design specification again we want to
emphasize the documentation process here
now that we've established the industry
standard origin of the qualification
from within regulations and standard for
process validation we can move into what
a qualification is
as most of you will be familiar there
are three components to a qualification
installation operational and performance
notice an additional box below pq on the
slide
here is where thermo fresher scientific
life sciences group differentiates ruo
and the ibd dx instrument products the
pq is performed with the dx or ibd
instruments and the ipv or instrument
performance verification
is performed with the ruo instruments to
be clear
for our audience this is strictly
thermo-fisher's scientific nomenclature
to differentiate our intermutation
for our purposes they are equivalent all
three components make a completed
qualification protocol
we will be speaking in more detail of
each of the qualification components as
well as
the difference between hardware pq and
workflow pq
moving on to the details the first
component of the qualification is
installation by definition the
installation qualification will
establish confidence that process
equipment and ancillary systems are
installed to the manufacturer's
recommendations
additional supporting details about
installation instruction and test
procedures can be found in section
820.170 installation
what does thermal scientific interpret
this to mean for the instrument
iq
it means we will verify and document
instrument or equipment against order
invoices any specific site requirements
any configuration details of the
instrument or equipment and specific
install criteria
it should be noted that
iq or installation qualification is not
repeated once the instrument or
equipment is successfully installed
follow-up qualifications would be called
oqpq
component 2 of the qualification is
operational by definition the
operational qualification
will establish confidence that process
equipment and ancillary systems are
capable of consistently operating within
the manufacturer's established limits of
specification and tolerances
additional supporting additional
supporting detail can be found in 820.72
inspection
measuring and test equipment
820.80 except acceptance activities and
subpart n 820.200
servicing
thermo-fisher scientific breaks down the
operational section into effective
subsystems of our instrument and
equipment
some examples of subsystem testing are
the internal self-test diagnostics
thermal testing
lamp or laser alignments
and
optical calibrations
final component of qualification is
performance qualification or instrument
performance verification
remember thermoscientific uses pq ports
dx or ibd instruments and ipv for its ru
instruments
by definition the performance
qualification or instrument performance
verification
will establish confidence that process
equipment and ancillary systems are
performing to the manufacturer's
recommendations by demonstration with
objective results
now this might be a bit confusing the
most common understanding of a pq is
of a pq or performance qualification is
the established limits and
specifications for the entire workflow
that were processed including equipment
instruments and software in the case of
thermal fissure scientific the
instrument hardware qualification the pq
component is focused on the workflow of
our instrument hardware not as the
larger workflow or process pq that the
instrument is being used in
our hardware pq establishes the utility
of the instrument and the standard
independently from
its suitability for the use of the total
process workflow
thus
the thermo fisher scientific instrument
hardware qualification becomes a
supporting element in the larger process
validation
unfortunately thermofister cannot
perform the process validation for you
some examples of hardware pq or ipv
standards thermo fisher scientific uses
in its instrumentation are an rna p
plate for quantitative pcr instruments
sequencing and g gene scan standards for
ce or capillary electrophoresis
instruments
and control beads or other synthetic
controls in our ngs or next-gen
sequencing products
now that we know what a qualification is
we can ask when are qualifications
required
all qualifications are recommended upon
installation or relocation after any
significant repair
post completion of planned maintenance
after any configuration changes such as
software revisions or hardware upgrades
and if the laboratory use changes
as moving from away from research into
sample processing or research into a
clinical environment
thermo fisher scientific uses a
risk-based approach in alignment with
fda philosophy to make recommendations
to customers after any critical or
significant repairs
let me provide an example
if a fuel service engineer replaces a
door or hinge and has nothing to do with
the
the
instrument operation or or the way it
generates data
then we would not recommend a
revalidation however if we replace a
halogen lamp that would affect
fluorescence or the
light path
would impact the data we would recommend
every qualification
why are qualifications important
qualifications are important documented
evidence as performance over time as we
have established in the previous slide
qualifications are a periodic and
ongoing necessity
qualifications support quality
management systems process validation
mitigate risks results or sample
integrity and provide evidence of
suitability
for the intended use
here are some myths
myth one validation of a process
equipment or instruments
is only done once
in fact no revalidation is required for
process changes reference 21cfr820.70b3
changes to equipment or instrument where
specification changes would trigger a
revalidation
revalidation should be performed if
performance or equipment
or instruments documented in the
qualifications show any deviation or
negative trends
also revalidation should be performed if
there are process failures or kappa
related activities
another myth is validation is only
necessary for processes where subsequent
verification is impossible that's not
true validation should be considered
even if your process include 100
verification 100 verification is not
necessarily 100 effective in a process
in myth 3 validations are burdensome
yes validations can be burdened and
costly but planning is key to mitigation
at this point
validation is also an investment in the
process equipment instrumentation and
personnel it helps you understand the
controls necessary to reduce variability
reducing variability reduces the risk to
results and reduces operational costs
a well-planned process validation
improves customer satisfaction and
confidence
myth four
my field service report or plan
maintenance report is sufficient to
document performance
that's not true to understand
why a service report or maintenance
protocol cannot stand in for a
qualification is because the intent of
the document this is how a potential
investigator will establish the utility
of documentation being performed by a
firm
the intent of service report is to
document the scope of the service event
being performed
a maintenance protocol intention is a
document the manufacturer's recommended
maintenance maintenance activities
activities to be formed
only a qualification is the industry
accepted negative into document
performance as called out in the
guidance documentation from the
international medical device regulators
forum and fda medical device quality
systems
requirements we spoke about earlier in
the webinar
the next two slides are a comparison of
thermo fisher scientific services and
associated details please take note of
the differences here
only the qualification has the intent to
document performance of the instrument
and provide documentation in a formal
signed protocol
in this second comparison slide please
take note of the differences
such as documentation lengths required
time to complete training and
certification
the qualification has significantly
different delivery and requirements
where are qualifications applicable
here is our attempt to align some of the
applicable standards and regulation to
the customer segments that should
consider process validation and
qualification services for thermo fisher
scientific as a manufacturer we will be
looking at part 820 and iso 9001-13485
for some of you in this audience your
interest may align with the clia cap and
iso 15189
but understand these are only some of
the more globally accepted markets for
qualification there will be many local
regional or international government
entities which will also support the use
of a qualification
to document performance of equipment
we recommend using the guidance
documents from global harmonization task
force international medical device
regulators forum and the us fda as
reference starting points
because science can't wait on
non-compliance
i would like to circle back on the
webinar learning objectives
we have summarized where qualification
comes from and the original origin of
the qualification as an industry
standard
we have explained process validation and
how it qual how a qualification fits
we've discussed what thermo fisher
scientific provides in its iq oq and pqs
and when they are required
we have reviewed why qualifications are
important to validation
we have also compared some details about
the different thermo fisher scientific
instrument services
thermo fisher scientific is very proud
of our mission providing compliance and
qualification services is one of the
many ways we support you as our customer
your laboratory process and quality
systems to make the world a healthier
cleaner and safer place
for more information about thermo fisher
scientific qualifications of
instrumentation equipment or other
compliance related products
we urge you to reach out and contact us
you can visit our webpage or email us
for additional details or call us to
have a conversation with one of our
specialists
we will be happy to address any
follow-up questions to our teams
on behalf of myself randall albright
bill and leicher representing thermo
fisher scientific life sciences we
appreciate your attendance in the
instrument qualification for quality
management system webinar
thank you
thank you justin for that informative
presentation
we've already received some great
questions already
first question we have is what are the
risks if i create or do the
qualification myself
yeah the the risk of a customer
developed protocol
may not be adequate to document
performance
being disconnected from the design
process typically leave the customer
protocol skipping operational areas that
would be captured by the manufacturer
doing the qualification
i hope that answers the
question yes thank you how much
time can i save by having the
manufacturer of record perform the
qualification
uh versus using in-house resources
yeah great question
i don't have a
statistics on this but the length of
time to develop a qualification protocol
would be dependent on the complexity of
the system
having a manufacturer qualify
allows quality systems to focus on the
risk tolerance of the workflow making it
making the equipment qualification more
plug-and-play to the validation process
so having the manufacturer perform the
validation
in the long run is the better idea
great we do have another question here
it says
how often should i requalify an
instrument
yeah this is
this is determined by the manufacturer's
recommendation and the risk tolerance of
the workflow thermo fisher uses a
risk-based determination to make
recommendations to requalify
at a minimum
for the lsg instrumentation we recommend
after any move
any pm or plan maintenance or after any
of those critical repairs that i
mentioned earlier that would affect data
so um
that that would be the times that you
would need to re-qualify the instrument
and justin how long does it take thermo
fish or scientific to perform their
qualifications services
yeah great question it varies quite a
bit
for the life sciences instruments
the lsg group it depends on the model or
platform but typically between half a
day
to two and a half days depending on the
platform um and then there is there's
documentation processing that usually
um
follows off-site and uh and then we will
deliver the entire package um you know
the qualification documents as well as
supporting attachments
um at the end of the
service
thank you justin that seems to be all
the questions we have right now at the
moment
so as a reminder to our audience
questions that we did not have time for
today
and even those that are submitted during
the on-demand period
will be addressed via the email address
you provided at the time of registration
so thank you again to our speaker justin
haugen and to everyone who participated
in the presentation we hope you enjoy
the rest of the event and please be sure
to check back frequently for new content
and presentations added throughout the
year
thank you
you